Dr House is out of control but so am I
let's watch this episode
we've got into an accident along the
canal road just outside Kingston
are you hurt she should have asked does
she have a pulse and if not Sir Charles
compressions
you're not fine you have a metal object
going through your body
ow
can we hurry this up make sure they take
your time
[Music]
Hannah morventhal
you have super Hannah morgenthal what is
cipa Autumn we have to do x-rays to make
sure you don't have internal injuries
blood tests to make sure no infections
EEG for neurological anomalies and
biopsy a spinal nerve I love how he just
decided that because he didn't like how
she was responding to the alcohol on her
leg and first of all who puts alcohol on
a leg all you need is a little soapy
water like alcohol actually disrupts the
skin tissue there only been about 60
documented cases yeah and I have
seven reasons to think that she's one of
them or she has moralgia peresthetica
and she's wearing a really tight belt
come on how's Shape Up reason number one
she knew what it was without us telling
her that's true but she could have also
been just acting tough you know because
some guy challenged her like you too
she's still wet from the snow she's not
shivering that's odd unless You Can't
Sweat or feel hot and cold the ambulance
was warm
I want to see my mother three scarring
around the lips and tongue when she was
a baby she chewed on herself without
feeling it I fell through a window when
I was a kid four you cleaned the wound
she flexed into the cleaner instead of
away from it it's hard to fake pain when
you've never felt it
takes an imaginative leap Ms morgenthal
she wants to see her mom she admits
having sea fish she knows we're not
letting her go anywhere without a
battery of tests if she already knows
she has sepa why run the battery of
tests I feel like house just like
wasting Hospital resources taking her to
see her mom
imagine he's wrong and he just hit a
poor kid
oh why am I laughing is this a real case
or one of those imaginary cases that
happen when you're bored sipa
zipper
diagnosis
diagnoses happen at the end of cases
thank you just got no idea what's going
on in her body it's bound to be
something wrong in other words she could
be perfectly healthy but you're curious
about someone who can't feel pain
because you always feel pain so you want
to go exploring or maybe because she has
sepa and was just involved in a major
car accident you should pan scan her
make sure she doesn't have internal
bleeding or injuries which would be a
very simple test that house doesn't need
to be present for and he can go home she
was in a car accident
sheets x-rays blood tests EEG nerve
biopsy what does she need an EEG for
what are you looking for if she's having
a seizure right now you can see if she's
having a seizure do your test except the
nerve biopsy you need the nerve you risk
paralyzing her what do you need a nerve
biopsy for I get it if it's congenital
we know there's no need looking for a
biopsy and a cause if the EEG reveals a
problem we can talk then but the EEG is
not a defining test EEG is going to show
you brain waves like what is that going
to tell you maybe they meant an EMG and
they're just using the wrong acronym
that's an EEG no idea why they're doing
it sparking on leads C3 and O2 she could
be going into a seizure
how about this I don't understand she it
could be you can't see it what do you
want us to do hold her down
but only until you inject her with the
sedative then you can let her go we
tried
seriously she's strong and doesn't care
we'd have broken something before we can
get her to sit still enough to inject
her so break her arm she won't mind
you're cranky I'm in pain and he's
jealous of her for not being in pain
little does he know a world without pain
is a much more dangerous and problematic
world than with pain
ironic every morning I have to check my
eyes to make sure I didn't scratch a
corny in my sleep oh God stop I'm in the
pool of Tears here I can't cry neither
can I every morning I check my eyes for
jaundice in case the vicodins finally
shot my liver I can't run anywhere
without examining all my toes for
swelling I can't run it's opposite ends
of the spectrum neither are good that's
why we have
homeostasis
I'm sick no your EEG was normal x-ray
showed no breaks blood tests show no
infections urine indicated don't
call code okay okay okay
you do not call a code because someone
becomes unresponsive she could be having
a seizure you don't need to call a code
a code is when someone's heart stops
for what
do you know what the condition is it's
not flush it's not sweating you must be
she's a temperature of 105. how does she
know oh because the thermometer was
still hanging on her mouth normally if
you are a healthy adult a fever will be
controlled if you have a rare condition
it can go out of control and actually
cause harm to your body that is why I'm
a proponent of in certain instances
decreasing the amount of Tylenol Advil
Motrin that we give to patients when
they have a mild fever because a mild
fever generally speaking doesn't do harm
in fact it allows your immune system to
work better and fight off infections
make your symptoms go away faster
improve your immune system make you uh
spend less time being infectious
infecting other people so like in this
case this is the rare instance where her
fever can fire her brain what if
we give her more pain signals a lot more
pain signals maybe some of them will
make it through you want to torture her
no
yes we do this to anybody else it's
torture doing it to her is no different
than pricking her finger we keep poking
sharp sticks into her eventually we'll
find the part that's already tender
since the most ridiculous thing I ever
heard of on the off chance that maybe
she might feel something and maybe we'll
poke the right area what if it's
internal what are you gonna do then
Chief is warm
the other
it's very hot
start here move to the hot one just a
few seconds then back we're going to
monitor activity in your brain while you
do it
feel any response to the Heat
could indicate a vascular problem
what
what she's still in surgery they tell me
it's going okay you can take your hand
out and you didn't ask anything else
take your hand out of the water
what's going on with my mother
you just got second degree burns
police missing chemicals in your nurse
heightened sensitivity
what on What planet this would never
happen
oh my God honestly I wish I was this
girl simply so I could sue this hospital
and become a billionaire judge jury they
drilled into my skull because maybe they
thought I'd feel it
I win that's it I win
so what I just sit here when you guys
drill a hole on me
just think about it if they drill like a
centimeter too deep and hurt her brain
and she becomes
functionally impaired
then what like they're pros and cons of
this are terrible
it's okay what you feel
where did you feel it
Anna I need to know how it hurt
what just happened in Egypt what are the
nerd biopsy show never did it well then
do it can't why she's gonna jump off the
lobby balcony
you think I can catch her
house is an ass
but what did he expect house to do
like for real though like maybe call
security I don't know like what do you
want from us what do you want us to do
you can't feel my legs you're trying to
pull the same stunt twice in 10 minutes
I'm not
[Music]
they couldn't have put something below
her so that if she did jump she would at
least have a padded surface
anything we're not looking for pain
anything at all pressure nothing
you have six broken bones a fever a
concussion erratic heart rhythms and a
complete lack of sensation below the
waist I feel fine
guilt
guilt as a symptom yeah I've never heard
of that Alzheimer's can cause Euphoria
pain causes depression and B12
deficiency causes guilt and she had a
B12 deficiency she would have been
anemic they would have seen that on the
CBC give her a shot of B12 and she gets
better I was right
or check her levels like I don't
understand I'm not happy
her white blood cell count was low the
ones she's got
a lot of eosinophils hyacinophils could
be a worm a parasitic infection
is it possible for you to just watch me
eat
or do you get some primeval thrill out
of beating the other Hunters to the food
B12 deficiency are you having Deja Vu
we've had this conversation she was
given B12 she didn't get better oh maybe
she is lacks intrinsic factor to bind it
does someone else ate it
get an abdominal MRI what
blush has a word
15. you're not going to anesthetize
magic trick
she's thinking
Lake fishing can be fun
they can bring the generations together
you know cook that trout or perch well
giving room and board to this fella
like Freeport I mean I'll be 12 you
could take in a tapeworm essentially
starts feeding on the foods that you're
consuming so it literally takes away
nutrients from you most commonly you can
get a B12 deficiency but then you would
also get a resulting anemia which is why
this episode's a little confusing
because they said the CBC was normal
outside of a low white count
I'm five feet long damn it
World Records over 60. they didn't see
the tapeworm on all of the Imaging that
they did this girl's case is interesting
because she has this condition she
doesn't feel anything therefore she's
not aware of the tapeworm and that's not
unusual a lot of people won't be aware
of a tapeworm but because she has this
tapeworm was not getting B12 she
essentially started having neurologic
complications as well as having a fever
because of the infestation of the worm
and all these other symptoms popped up
but at the same time they didn't pop up
like they normally would it in a healthy
individual her presentation was masked
because she has the condition sipa house
I'm challenging you to not flinch during
my reaction video
still drawing those lines instead of
looking at the cards
time to Institute the Heimlich maneuver
and stop bullying your child it's
impossible smack a treat what do you
mean it's impossible what is mac and
cheese unchokable
all right the fact that he's yelling
though makes it a little bit less likely
that he's actually choking if you're
yelling that means you're moving air 10
year old boy screams for his life for no
reason he's autistic severely autistic
okay so a child with autism what we have
is an autism spectrum disorder and we
don't know where in that Spectrum this
child lies can't talk can't make eye
contact screaming's probably his way of
communicating yeah you know some
children that have been diagnosed with
autism one of the challenges that they
face is verbal and non-verbal
communication some children don't have
good social cue identification where
they can't understand someone's emotion
by reading their body language or they
can't speak themselves or they choose
not to speak themselves his brain can
filter information is a constant assault
on his senses I'd scream too one of the
main things that go hand in hand with
the ASD hypersensitivity sometimes to
light touch sound and remember while
we're only naming the challenges there
are some positives that can come from a
diagnosis of ASD some children are super
smart some have the ability to memorize
things way better than the average child
so it's not only about the challenge
it's about the strengths too EO attracts
throat no obstruction it's nothing which
means the only symptom was a screen
which is diagnostic of nothing I
completely agree with Foreman you have a
child who is diagnosed with autism who
started screaming and the parents are
very worried about it and now they're
doing like this giant workup with
multiple Specialists I wouldn't even
know what the consultation would ask of
the specialist let's do a sample a chick
to parasites blood culture to rule out
infection and Ana for Lupus because he
screamed I love investigating if there
is an investigation warranted you're
checking for OVA and parasites and lupus
you can't order tests willy-nilly
because false positives are really a
thing dust wheat pollen the toxin or
something it could literally be anything
because right now your One symptom is
screaming run along ventilation scan
lungs are in the chest too right I had a
date last night she screamed should we
spend a hundred thousand dollars testing
her what is your date scream that was a
weird revelation of course not this
isn't the veterinary Hospital see
actually the Veterinary Hospital thing
is kind of funny to me because in
medicine we oftentimes say treating kids
working in Pediatrics is a lot like
being a vet because sometimes the
children if they're really young can't
tell you what's wrong with them so it's
almost like treating a dog who can't
tell you what's wrong with them either
you know what it's going to be like
trying to put an autistic kid into a
nuclear scanner I don't envy you guys in
those cases we do sedate we give
medications like benzodiazepines for
temporary sedation
can't you sedate him or something could
if I don't want the test results to mean
anything are they doing a CT if they're
doing a CT you could sedate the child I
don't know why you said that the test
won't mean anything
[Music]
yeah did they just break into people's
homes all the time
big shocker dad's depressed and they're
getting information on the parents this
is so unethical
[Music]
on a screaming child is cost 10
they're gonna test his sand out of his
sandbox who's paying for this I can't
get insurers to pay for an antibiotic if
it comes in an easier to swallow capsule
and they're going to get insurance to
pay for sand testing come out fecal
matter is there a sample we can look at
parents have the smear kit the kid is
constipated go up his rear and get a
smear talk about creating a traumatic
situation for a child for absolutely
zero reason at this time but somehow
because it's a House MD episode he's
gonna be right I don't even know what
they're looking for in this fear they
already got it over a parasite sample
so what makes fluid fill the lining of
the kids lungs infection tumor I feel
like I'm one of his students just
yelling stuff out if there's a plural
effusion we have to rule out heart
failure the plural by the way is the
lining that covers the lungs organs are
covered by pleural membranes which
essentially prevents the organs from
rubbing all over each other so like
there's a cardiac membrane there's a
lung membrane get the kid Nick of
cardiogram
Adam very hard to perform an echo as is
but to perform one on an uncooperative
patient or combative patient even harder
um
what
what is it is this heart okay
Echo suggested a conduction abnormality
EKG confirmed it a conduction
abnormalities basically when there's a
problem with electrical conductivity of
the heart so basically in one part of
your heart you have a node that starts
your cardiac Rhythm and then it travels
throughout the rest of the heart the
reason it has to travel throughout this
conductive system is because you don't
want the entire heart beating
simultaneously otherwise it's going to
have all the blood just Splat against
each other but if you have the top of
the heart beat first and then the bottom
of the heart beats then you can have
like a rhythmical pulsation of the blood
throughout the heart get along the
biopsy well it took a half an hour to
get the mask on the kid for the lung
scan oh I'm sorry was there somewhere
you needed to be what are they going to
do a bronchoscopy I don't understand how
they're going to do a long biopsy like
Interventional Radiology what part of
the lung are they going to test this
makes no sense this is brutal we want to
do a lung biopsy lung biopsies usually
come back negative so biopsy lymph node
under the arm
[Music]
not change your biopsy results and the
child will not be further traumatized by
this medical experience hope is what's
making them miserable
what they should do is get a Cocker
Spaniel
dog would look him in the eye wag his
tail when he's happy animal therapy for
children with autism can actually be
quite beneficial there's less judgment
that comes from animals almost no
judgment actually the interaction that
you could have with the animal is so
much simpler that is an easier
introduction to human interaction which
is much more complex horses dogs that
kind of thing supportive animals really
go a long way for children who have
autism not for all but in some cases no
cancer
because these aren't lymph cells then
what are they okay let me try and guess
these aren't lymph cells so what did he
get a biopsy of a huge sweat gland an
abscess a dermatofibroma oh my God what
could have he gotten oh oh a Teratoma
that has hair cells in oh I can't have
no idea liver cells so you have liver
cancer that is metastasized to his
armpit what's the difference between
cancer cells and liver cells why can one
pass through walls but the other can't
cancer cells are damage lets them grow
into blood vessels go wherever they want
so if the liver cells are damaged liver
isn't damaged the tests were normal well
tests on a liver being normal doesn't
necessarily mean the liver is normal
because the tests that we use to check
liver function which we call liver
function test it's actually a misnomer
they're actually liver inflammation
tests that tell us if the liver is
damaged thereby releasing liver enzymes
and if these liver enzymes are elevated
then we know there's a problem with the
liver however if your liver is so
diseased that it's in the end stage of
liver cancer cirrhosis those numbers can
be normal because your liver is almost
fried and there's no enzymes left to be
had it's not as liver it's heart or his
lungs
calcium carbonate in this stool it was
constipated parents probably just
overdid it maybe he ate a bunch of chalk
or tubs or they didn't do it at all
calcium carbonates also what's in
shocking cause the pleural effusion
forget the chalk the kid's got pica
take him to a buffet he's gonna eat the
table Pika it's a condition where you
start eating things that are not edible
paint off of the walls mud show me what
you hate
[Music]
foreign
started in his lung which caused the
pleural effusion then a metastasized
with liver which made it slow cells no
it has to be some kind of worm traveling
throughout his body
I'm seeing them all the time
what are you looking for he's telling us
what you're seeing telling us exactly
what was wrong with him
drawing them for us over and over again
hello my pretty nematodes it's not a
tumor Foreman it's worms we said we also
said everything else so I'm not gonna
even take credit for animal mix potty
sandbox boy plays in the sandbox boy
eats the sand you can probably tell
where this is going by now still samples
were negative for parasites raccoon
round worms are not excreted by their
human host Cameron tested bro stop
acting like you knew about raccoon poop
without looking it up I swear worms
spread from his gut to the rest of his
body he attacked his lungs that's what
screaming I don't even care that he knew
it was raccoon poop it's the fact that
he knew humans don't release it in their
own fecal matter if that information
that ever becomes useful to me for some
weird way I'm gonna send a thank you
letter to the writers of the show attack
his eye and the muscles surrounding it
making his eyeball do a backflip
laser photo coagulation to fix the eye
and a high dose of benzambitazole to
kill the worms just think about the
sequence of events here child that's
diagnosed with autism comes in screaming
into the ER house immediately starts
running tests on him and finally gets
down to it that he ate raccoon poop from
a Sandbox how did we get here hey guys
you requested House MD did I get bonus
points if I act like I care let's get
started
[Music]
this reminds me of where I grew up in
Brooklyn or is this a jail
like the answer I already know the
answer I missed the boss I don't doubt
it no bus stops near Brad's every
medical show has to start off with some
kind of sexual thing medicine is so
exciting as it is why does there have to
be sex just calm down stop having sex
for a second you should never keep
anything from your parents and I told
mine
laughs
what
happened
are we having a stroke
slurred speech classic sign of a stroke
up
problems with moving the arms
call 9-1-1
[Music]
we know that we're the
oh
[Music]
no
oh that's a seizure
she is having a general toniconic
seizure putting on your old female for a
seizure one month ago lost the ability
to speak babbled like a baby Progressive
deterioration of mental status
see that we all assume that I'm
impatient because of this King so put on
a white coat like the rest of us I want
him to think I'm a doctor you see where
the administration might have a problem
without having to do people don't want a
sick doctor now wearing your white coat
I guess it's not really a big deal
because sometimes I go without my white
coat and just wear my stethoscope it's
really for infectious purposes only so
that if you get any kind of germs on you
you don't bring it back home to your
family or if obviously some blood
splatters on you or some other bodily
fluid I guess brain tumor she's gonna
die boring
uh that was a little cold she's 29
Whatever She's Got is the protein marker
is the three most prevalent brain
cancers came up negative two more
markers for brain cancer that's not how
we diagnose brain tumors we use Imaging
that's the gold standard for brain
tumors obviously in addition to biopsy
if needed but tumor markers are not a
way to rule out a Cancer and she's not
responding to radiation treatment none
of which is even close to this positive
medically I'm very confused there's a
patient who had a seizure they think
that she has a tumor they did some lab
work doesn't show she has a tumor
they're giving her radiation even though
that they don't see a tumor I could not
be more confused right now or this
totally doesn't make sense medical
medically shouldn't we be speaking to
the patient before we start diagnosing
[__] doctor no but everybody lies Dr
house doesn't like dealing with
patients isn't treating patients why we
became doctors no treating illnesses is
why we became doctors treating patients
is what makes most doctors miserable so
you're trying to eliminate the humanity
from the practice of medicine if we
don't talk to them they can't lie to us
excuse me Dr house you can have a good
conversation with patients you don't
need to believe every word they say you
can be honest you can say you don't know
but give a plan of what you're doing
about not knowing so basically how are
you getting to the answer first you have
medical school if you hear her feet you
should think horses not zebras very
common phrase lab and Trenton could have
screwed up the blood test
I assume it's the corollary if people
lie that people screw up
redraw the blood tests and get our
schedule for that Contrast MRI ASAP
let's find out what kind of zebra we're
treating here so a Contrast MRI
basically allows you to see what blood
vessels are doing within the brain the
fact that they're going to a lab and
questioning if the lab is accurate we do
do that occasionally but that's not the
first thing we think about I guess
because this case is more complex I was
expecting my office 20 minutes ago
really well that's odd because I had no
intention of being in your office 20
minutes ago you think we have nothing to
talk about no we just can't think of
anything I'd be interested in I sign
your paychecks I continue
I can still fire you if you're not doing
your job right here from nine to five
your Billings are practically
non-existent What Fear you ignore
requests for console I call back
sometimes years behind on your
obligations I was right this doesn't
interest me six years times three weeks
you owe me better than four months five
o'clock I'm going home doctors don't
work nine to fives we have crazy
schedules if someone that's more senior
to us obviously like our boss like she
is in this case tells you to get
something done you're getting it done
but also because we have a love for the
job we want to treat patients I don't
know why he's being the sarcastic guy
but I will say it's really funny I'm
angry
designed to scare me because I'm not
sure what it is I'm supposed to be
scared of more yelling that's not scary
that you're gonna hurt me that's scary
but I'm pretty sure I can outrun you
[Applause]
okay that's cool that he's popping pills
on the job oh this is in Jersey
Plainsboro
[Music]
I work in New Jersey all right Rebecca I
know I know you feel a little
claustrophobic in there but we need you
to remain still it's very true that
people get claustrophobic in MRIs you
have to have to lay there for an
extended period of time the noise is
very loud so there are times that I have
to pre-medicate my patients and give
them a dose of a benzodiazepine like
Xanax most commonly that you're probably
familiar with
yeah it's really loud it's even Louder
Than This
I don't feel so good
it's all right just try to relax
I'll be sharing another seizure
Rebecca
okay
[Music]
is she having an anaphylactic attack to
the contrast
get her out of there I should probably
fell asleep she's exhausted she was
claustrophobic 30 seconds ago she's not
sleeping
she's having allergic reaction to
Catalina which should be dead oh no get
her out EpiPen into the upper thigh
quick
[Music]
fashion
she's not breathing at 3.5
I can't ventilate
too much edema where's the surgical
Airway you're gonna need to go in the
neck and do a tracheostomy
okay that's way too big of an incision
okay not exactly how that goes if you're
allergic to the contrast that they gave
for the MRI it's possible that you can
get this anaphylactic attack which means
that your Airway starts closing down
basically your throat swells up to the
point where you can no longer oxygenate
some people also vomit some people get
very nauseous blood pressure drops her
Airway close up to the point where she
couldn't breathe but because it's her
throat closing up and swelling if you
make an incision in the trachea right
here where there's a soft little spot
for an opening you can continue helping
the patient breathe I'm gonna call some
inaccuracies here if a patient turns
blue like that you're hitting a code
blue there's an emergency team coming
nurses doctors respiratory therapists
you also got to get IV set you got to
figure out why the patient's heart
stopped or stopped breathing there's a
lot more that has to happen you don't
just automatically assume it has
something to do with the contrast that
you gave and he's still popping pills
what is he popping hope those are Advil
you actually want me to talk to the
patient get a history
we need to know if there's some genetic
or environmental cause treasuring an
inflammatory response I thought
everybody lied
truth begins and lies
so why did you tell him to not talk to
the patient initially Dr House
truth begins and lies just means that in
order to find out the truth you have the
person lie to you and from there you can
then start making a deduction on what
part they're lying about so you need to
hear the lie that's why it definitely
makes sense to always talk to patients
first regardless if you believe that
they're telling the truth or not what
are you doing painkillers oh for you for
your life no because they're yummy you
want one make your back feel better
no don't do it that's how the opioid
crisis started house why are you so
afraid of making a mistake because I'm a
doctor
because when we make mistakes people die
yeah come on
people used to have more respect for
cripples you know
they didn't really
I can't see
oh
she's having a seizure again
so turning a patient on their side is
the smartest move because you want them
to if they're going to vomit they don't
aspirate when you arrange these
to tell a story
this is a type of neurological testing
to see if the person can follow a series
of events a couple headaches last month
mild fever sometimes I can't sleep and I
have trouble concentrating
apparently not while researching the
stuff on the internet
I was thinking it also might be fibro
myalgia
excellent diagnosis is there anything
before that
36 bike I didn't change for a dollar
36 bike in it and change
oh Placebo
he's gonna give sugar pills oh and he's
stealing the Vicodin for himself again
obviously doctors don't swap out
medications if we prescribe something to
the patient we send an order to Pharmacy
and the pharmacist fill the order and we
don't replace them with sugar pills for
placebo effect since you didn't find
anything everything I found was I found
ham oh so
where there's ham there's pork or
there's pork there's Neurosis to
psychosis that's the condition
tapeworm see it fits it's perfect it
explains everything but it proves
nothing I can prove it by treating no
you can't
I was just with her she doesn't want any
more treatments she doesn't want any
more experiments she wants to go home
and die that's called the principle of
uh autonomy basically that a patient has
the right to refuse treatment at any
point as long as they're competent and
by competent I means that they're able
to understand the consequences of their
actions so if they say they want to go
home and you tell them you can possibly
die if you go home they can say that
back to you and understand what that
means they're free to go home for being
an idiot
you have a tapeworm in your brain
it's that pleasant but if we don't do
anything you'll be dead by the weekend
he's right we should x-ray her but we
don't x-ray her brain we x-ray her leg
worms love thigh muscle she's got one in
her head I guarantee you there's one in
her leg
um I did not know this
this is uh beyond my expertise and
probably most doctors expertise
[Music]
this here
is a worm lover wow so if it's in my leg
it's in my brain are you looking for a
guarantee
it's there probably been there six to
ten years how does he know that
he's giving her a dewormer if anyone
asks you have 11 daughters and five Sons
wait that's 16 students they said her
class has 20 what are the other five why
did they show up oh wait 11-5 sorry the
other four we're happier now
I wanna hook
a hug right now don't give the kids the
worms I'm just kidding Dr house you have
a patient
[Music]
he says he needs a refill
that change per dollar
that's funny patient got hooked on them
uh
Tic Tacs house I'm looking at you sir
are you gonna give me a zebra or a horse
I don't know let's check it out on This
House MD medical review what are you
kidding me type of good there's got to
be over six bills you ain't gonna lift
them with a couple of blankets
yeah just roll them off but he's already
dead ain't like he's gonna feel there's
actually a situation that some of my
paramedic friends discussed with me
about legitimately having trouble
getting humans outside of their homes
into the ambulance and into the ER
there's been even been times that I've
heard them talk about injuring
themselves bringing patients out of
their homes because they were perhaps
overweight or obese or perhaps their
environment wasn't safe all right one
two flip
oh
whoa it wasn't me either
don't look at me
is the patient alive did no one check
for a pulse trust me Skin's cold pupils
are fixed and dilated he's not breathing
he's got a pulse he's not dead if he has
a pulse 46 year old guy in a coma
doesn't appear to be anything wrong with
him except the fact that he weighs over
600 pounds who says that who who talks
about a patient's weight like that and
says there's probably nothing wrong do
you know that do you know his history he
can't even give you his full history
there's no way you could have results
this quickly like at least get an
echocardiogram blood sugar's normal
cholesterol is lower than mine toxic
screen's clean no sign of trauma I'm
sure there wasn't a mix-up with the lab
three times I'm glad that they rechecked
because if a clinical picture meaning
what a patient looks like behaves like
or symptoms are like don't match the
labs you should be rechecking those labs
too many times I've had that happen
recheck the labs and find out they're
completely normal or the other way
completely abnormal so I always like to
keep laboratory error in the back of my
mind or in the front of my mind the
Forefront of my mind my mind there's
nothing thing abnormal in the EEG or the
neurological exam who gets an e when a
patient just rolls in it's too soon you
should get a CAT scan see what the lungs
are like get an echo see what the
anatomy of the heart is like you should
see what the digestive system is like
with a CAT scan when a patient comes in
and you don't know what's going on you
have to throw all the tests at the
patient in order to understand what's
going on you need to check for substance
abuse you need to check for toxic
metabolites complete metabolic panel the
complete blood count look at all these
values and not just jump to conclusions
I mean like doing EEG seems like the
50th step and they've skipped over 1
through 49. improperly prepared puffer
fish can have toxins that could cause a
coma and might not show up on the talk
screen then if it was a puffer fish he'd
be dead in six to eight hours time she's
been in a coma at least 24. how do
people know this fact about puffer fish
come on Foreman you didn't know that you
Googled it he Googled it this is
ridiculous a person shouldn't be able to
eat themselves into Oblivion and then
just expect everyone to pull out the
stocks to fix everything what are we
supposed to do refuse treatment to
anyone who's obese come on give me a
break this guy's on my face she's not
even morbidly obese he's suicidal people
who attempt suicide get treated when you
have non-compliant diabetics don't wait
non-compliant diabetics do get treated I
don't know why he said that and patients
who are addicted to food or perhaps have
an emotional issue that is causing them
to overeat and become 600 pounds or
perhaps have a medical condition that's
causing them to gain this much weight
shouldn't be judged like you can't be a
doctor and be this judgey and be
successful as a clinician you should do
an LP with neurosyphilis it's not
syphilis how do you know whatever he has
is connected to his gut now what's below
it MRA his brain look for clots she said
that the blood was drawn three times in
that time they couldn't check for
syphilis
one two three
not gonna lie this is a true challenge
for hospital and Hospital Systems when
patients can't fit in the equipment
that's why we are trying to create newer
equipment that is more capable in
handling patients of all different sizes
and shapes leads clots and clocks I
don't see any edema either so what do we
do now
NLP even if it's not an STD a fever boys
towards some sort of infection I'm not
sure we can do an LP and a guy his size
do they get a chest x-ray like if you at
least had a chest x-ray you could do
that portable you could do it right in
the bed you could see if that there is a
lung infection you could rule that out
check the urine see if there's a urinary
tract infection with a pyelonephritis
going up to the kidneys like why aren't
they talking about the most common
things this show is all about zebras not
horses remember that saying when you
hear hoof beets think horses not zebras
doesn't mean you forget the zebras just
means you think the horse is first
trying
we still have no idea why he was in the
coma to begin with OR why he woke up
what if it is hormones
adrenal insufficiency could cause a
temporary comb it can and also a thyroid
storm can cause a coma although a
thyroid storm would probably come with a
rapid heart rate also not weight gain if
you have a hyperactive thyroid although
if you have an underactive thyroid
followed by thyroid storm which can
happen because the thyroid even in like
certain conditions like Hashimoto's and
Graves disease sometimes it flips on and
off between hyper and hypothyroid it's
not always so clearly defined especially
in the beginning of the onset of disease
to later stages of disease you should do
a full STD panel and check his genitals
for shankers well first of all you
should have checked them for shankers
beforehand and you should have done a
full STD panel beforehand it's like the
cheapest test you can do if you're
talking about all these MRIs that you're
breaking costing millions of dollars the
300 STD panel would have been worth it
don't you think you having any problems
with your vision now I have nystagmus
I've had it since birth I'm fine you're
not fine you're in a coma for two days
there's something wrong with you was
something wrong with me now I'm better
now I'd like to go home the patient can
always leave like if he can think about
the consequences if the patient can
verbalize those consequences and it's
safe for them to leave in that sense
they can choose to leave they will leave
against medical advice which is an AMA
but it's within their rights it's
patient autonomy wait let us take you
all the way outside I'm fine but it
doesn't matter it's Hospital rules oh
screw the rules I've been on my back for
four days I need the exercise right
George come on let us just take you to
the taxi don't worry I may not be able
to climb Everest but I can walk
[Music]
first of all if a patient has not gotten
up since he's been admitted to the
hospital would get a PT evaluation to
see if he's capable of walking on his
own and if he's not he cannot safely go
home alone he would at least need to go
to a Subacute rehab stay where he could
learn how to walk on his own and take
care of himself because if a patient
can't get up and walk you're essentially
setting them up for failure by sending
them home
I think we should focus on the coma and
the fever we have a rather large piece
of tempered glass that begs to differ I
just mean it's not connected how could
you possibly know because I did it
I didn't think he should be discharged
so I gave him three grams of penetone
what hospital
she dragged the patient so he wouldn't
leave oh my God
don't poison your patience even if you
think it's right for them because you
are not God
what would happen to her medical license
loss we'll do it in order they find out
medical Review Committee Medical Board
suspension followed by Medical Board
revaluation followed by loss of medical
license either temporarily or forever
depending on how angry the patient is
prior situations etc etc
lawyer up it can't be joggers he's never
been outside the country his stomach has
the food we eat no longer comes from
America's Heartland it comes from South
America's deforested jungle land where
lettuce now grows and let his Pickers
now poop in a sample of his CSF how are
you going to get a sample of his
cerebrospinal fluid that's going to be
tough you want to drill a hole in my
head it's got to be something other than
a parasite by my protest it's the best
Market in town and I always wash it
leafy vegetables can set contaminated
water through the roots right into the
plant I've never heard this this sounds
far-fetched but I hope they research
this
please tell me this is a neurosurgeon
doing this not like Foreman
it's forming oh my God these they're all
neurosurgeons infectious disease
specialists Family Medicine doctors
cardiologists they run MRI machines all
cramp what what'd you do nothing why
what's wrong I can't I can't say
vision's blurry or you've lost it I
didn't lose it you took it from George
calm down this is actually why patients
are kept awake during some neural
procedures because in case you do touch
something you want to know right away so
that you don't continue doing damage in
that area blindness plus coma says
diabetes no blood sugar urine dipstick
and hemoglobin A1c are normal we're
normal when you test it
out of a coma whatever's going on is
waxing waning that's not true because a
hemoglobin A1c gives you an average of
the blood sugars over the last three
months so it doesn't mean it was normal
today it could be different tomorrow it
still will give you the average of the
last three months so I don't agree with
house here I'm not diabetic sooner you
drink this the sooner I get to go waste
my time with something else get the hell
off of me no dessert till you finished
your dinner
such a classic house situation where
he's just losing his mind fighting a
patient
go
wait his liver's failing now is
jaundiced what's happening he had X-rays
of his hands tell him that lung cancer
is in no way connected to obesity uh you
don't think he'll realize we're lying or
not lung Cancer's got nothing to do with
me about him having lung cancer he
didn't notice his fingers
I noticed they were fat I should have
pissed him off he would have grabbed you
I mean you would have felt the bones
they're not just fat they're clubbed
[Music]
this is the first x-ray they're getting
are you joking he was in a coma in the
ICU and they're just getting an x-ray
now
oh they're getting an X-ray of his hand
I thought this is their first chest
x-ray they're getting your tests were
positive
you have a small cell lung carcinoma
caused a peroneoplastic neurologic
syndrome perineoplastic basically means
that as a result of having this tumor it
secreted hormones that have altered the
way that his body behaves it's
approval but
[Music]
they might give you a few more months
I never smoked not all lung cancer cases
are caused by smoking some are caused by
asbestos
I would ask if he had any questions at
that point I mean you're just delivering
a life-changing diagnosis you spend 10
seconds and you leave I think that's
kind of cold
Ebola is Ebola hey
we're all in quarantine because of this
coronavirus pandemic I thought there's
no better time to watch a House MD
episode about a quarantine
can I see
oh
get her tell
what was in that jar
this acting is awful smallpox was
eradicated over 30 years ago so we're
Hush Puppies if you checked out your
local hipster coffee shop lately
smallpox doesn't exist outside of P4
labs and bio weapon Plants so that's
actually true I believe there's only
four Labs or four locations in the world
that have samples of smallpox still
available for testing because we felt
like there would still be uh worthwhile
evidence that we can collect from how
this virus spreads how we can eradicate
it we've limited because of the fear of
bioterrorism she wasn't Bermuda where
she was scuba diving on the wreck of a
Dutch slave ship that had been
intentionally sunk because an epidemic
of smallpox have broken out on board
house always presents himself to know
these just absurd things how does he
know that she was in this shipwreck like
I want to be in the room where he's
questioning his patients when a patient
comes into my office they have high
fever vomiting I don't ask if they've
been on a pirate ship lately like I just
can't imagine how he extracts that bit
of information thanks for calling back
uh listen I'm a screenwriter and and is
it theoretically possible for smallpox
to survive for more than 200 years
underwater in a sealed glass jar
thank you can you imagine just call the
CDC and ask random questions like that
isolate get Baseline blood draws for
smallpox antibodies and vaccinate the
entire family okay first of all I can't
imagine what lab is gonna do smallpox
testing nowadays it has to be Ascend and
test to Atlanta for the CDC headquarters
are there's like I don't have tests for
that in my office especially on my epic
the electronic medical record I think if
I put in small blocks it'll give me some
major alert to tell me to contact the
CDC we should test for the 21st century
suspects varicilla measles they're free
to perform whatever unnecessary tests
you want Foreman in all honesty form in
here is a hundred thousand percent
correct if a young woman presents to the
office with high fever vomiting and
bloodshot eyes you should rule out
everything that it's most likely to be
well first anything that's most likely
to be deadly smallpox should be way way
low on the list of differential
diagnoses when I think about that old
school saying when you hear hoof beats
you should think horses not zebras
because thinking about zebras Miss some
pretty important cases that are easily
treatable like to influenza virus like
measles
why the hell do you guys have us
quarantined in here we're just taking
every precaution against what so I think
this is a great time to explain the
difference between isolation and
quarantine isolation is when you take
someone who is sick and diagnosed sick
with a specific virus or bacteria and
you keep them isolated from other people
there's different forms of isolation
droplet Airborne contact what have you
then if you're wondering if someone has
potentially been exposed by something
they may or may not be sick they can be
held in quarantine not isolation that's
what I'm doing here I'm technically in
quarantine because I'm not sick I may or
may not become sick but that's what
we're all doing social distancing that
does not look like tetanus shots it's
really not worth going into because the
odds are astronomical
tell me
again it's smallpox
smallpox that would have been really
awesome if she just said you know what
you should do you should stay alert not
anxious I've been really proud of the
House MD show from doing that negative
for virus a lot of measles so all of our
ideas are off the table I'm putting mine
back on this is a diver under increased
pressure everything the blood gets
scared panics runs and hides antibodies
could be in the joints tap our knee
ankle shoulder any other joint in her
smallpox written body doing a joint
aspiration to check if it is in fact
smallpox seems kind of dangerous there
are true times where you need to do a
joint aspiration like if a patient has
septic arthritis and you need to Culture
The Joint fluid to see what antibiotics
you should use or if you're looking for
gout but just to do it on the off chance
that she may or may not have smallpox
that actually puts the patient at risk
for septic arthritis which is a
bacterial infection of the joint
oh no what does he see
what is it
I'm sorry
I have to call the CDC I don't know what
he said I think you do have smallpox
blisters but take a look at this
what is it there's a rash under your
daughter's arm
like more of those gross bumps
it's a regular rash
what does that mean
he's just not smallpox I don't know why
not because that still can be a small
pox rash
explain it to me I'm Dr Broda head of
infection control CDC and your
protective suits are not adequate turns
out they don't have to be rash under the
arm means it's not smallpox false alarm
sorry hope the traffic wasn't too bad
rash is consistent with smallpox not if
it presents after pustules she's
probably just allergic to the bed sheets
of the hospital gown or you simply
didn't notice it we're going to airlift
Blood and Tissue samples to Atlanta
we'll have the DNA results in 18 hours
in the meantime please
step out of the room it's funny I find
myself agreeing with the CDC doctor more
than I am with Dr house but I know it's
probably to my demise
sir are you feeling all right in there
it's just a headache oh no his eyes
evening
baby
oh god dad and you're bleeding
is this Ebola
[Music]
why have they stopped
you can't go out there why did you stop
get out of the hallway he does not have
smallpox yes he does
he's just developed pustules he's now
too dangerous to transport the virus
that causes smallpox is called variola
and before we had vaccinations we used
to do valuation where you take a piece
of the pustule that people develop and
you introduce it to somebody in order to
inoculate them meaning to get their
immune system ready to face the real
smallpox that wasn't as good as the
vaccines we are today we have today
because you actually got sick with
smallpox at that case however your case
wasn't as bad as those who caught it
naturally so this was a way to get sick
but not as sick as everyone else it was
only until we got to smallpox vaccine
were we truly able to eradicate smallpox
from the world
oh wait
the soles of your feet
there aren't any lesions no pustules on
the daughter's Palms so so therefore
your theory is you asked me to take the
dad's blood but I accidentally injected
him with smallpox exactly although
technically was the vaccinia virus which
is what the smallpox vaccine is made
from same symptoms this is smallpox but
only half the calories and almost none
of the lethality you sound like one of
those anti-vaccine cranks you can't
develop full bone symptoms from the
vaccine this quickly you can if you're
immunocompromised
I'm the only one who reads these things
get a kidney cancer six years ago he's
been in remission well it's obviously
back I swear our house just walks around
and throws diagnoses on everyone that
could be possible and I feel like he
does this so inaccurately that he has
such a low success rate it doesn't
matter because at the end of the day
each time it gets proven wrong he'll
figure out something else that he can
throw out there and he'll be right not a
fan of this approach not very realistic
you got any proof the kidney cancers
back well let me give him this when he
gets better that'll be the proof you
need I'll put on one of your fancy space
suits and I promise I won't kiss them on
an open sore you know who Janet Parker
is that's the last person who died of
smallpox in 1978 she was working at a
university in England someone in a
research lab on the floor below screwed
up some smallpox virus managed to float
up through the vents into the room where
she was working
she died four days later
last known person to die from smallpox
and the person in charge of the lab was
so destroyed
he killed himself wow
didn't know that now that he's shedding
I can't open that door for anyone when
he says now that he's shedding he's
talking about the pustules that is the
most infectious stage of smallpox so you
don't want to be anywhere near a person
if they truly do have it
hey oh no house
hey this is textbook smallpox
ddxing at this point
say that
house
you screwed up going in there
[Music]
chest compressions chest compressions
chest compressions
even house fails us with the chest
compressions he's starting to get the
defibrillator ready instead of doing
chest compressions I know he's not by
himself but still and I'm pretty sure
the Rhythm I saw pop up there was
Flatline you don't shock Flatline either
house you know better than that if the
cat get sick smallpox is exclusive to
humans is this toxoplasmosis for pets
nothing and nobody went on those ships
if it didn't have a purpose hunting mice
and rats for the crew the hold was
probably infested with mice
what if that's the difference what
happened to Herod
ah is that a sad awe or a cute uh died
ah
before he died did he lose his fur
how did you know
mice don't carry smallpox but they do
carry rickettsial bugs my knowledge of
rickettsia pox is not up to date
rickettsia pox is a mild self-limited
zoonotic febrile illness characterized
by escar formation at the location of a
Mite bite following the onset of
systemic symptoms in a more generalized
papular vesicular rash rickettsial pox
occurs Primary in urban areas where
density of mites mice and humans is high
they named it in 1946 in New York City
shout out NYC in about 2007 there's been
14 cases reported approximately 1.7
cases per million people that's why I
haven't seen it at least look at the
Dad's Body small patches of black dead
tissue will prove I'm right
escars appear with rickettsial pox but
not with smallpox if he had developed
escars I would have noticed
scar
escars
scars just dead tissue on the body you
frequently see it with absencies meaning
when someone has a pocket of infection
but it's very common appearing of where
the patient was bitten by a Mite in our
pox start the girl on doxycycline right
now
I still wouldn't take off my gear like
that oh my God just because you saw that
S car could have been caused by anything
my God this is ridiculous infection
control people this would never happen
in any Hospital ever ever ever If This
truly happened in this matter in a
hospital house would still be kept under
quarantine just in case he didn't have
another infectious condition because God
forbid you left them you let them out
too early and now he's walking around
infecting all the future patients he
sees in his colleagues no way no no way
I was riding a city bike the other day
and someone screamed Dr Mike we want
more House MD here we go House MD number
three
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
yeah sure
I think you are are they both
gonna be patients in this episode
wow that's a lot of blood
[Music]
and a little poker
Ducati got one of your patients in the
ER be in Austin six years old uh oh I
know him what's the problem I'm all in
bloody diarrhea hemodynamically stable
but he's been developing some
coordination problems it sounds like
gastroentonitis and dehydration order
fluids and I'll take it on my Surface
that's you house they scan his head no
why would they don't play games
heart rate stable after
I was not going anywhere put the order
in and have someone tell Alan and Sarah
that I'll be up when I'm done
I hope that's a non-alcoholic beverage
in her hand if you're on call and you're
going to be admitting patience to your
service you probably shouldn't be
drinking alcohol just saying Stone Cold
Bluff you might want to spend a little
more time paying attention to your cars
and a little less time staring at my
breasts they don't match either I used
to play poker semi-professionally during
my college days I would play online
before it was banned and I would uh make
some money not a lot of money it was
more about a learning experience but the
friends that I played with we constantly
use poker as an analogy for everything
we did in life whether it was medicine
talking to girls relationships with our
friends we would always somehow relate
it back to Poker and I feel like that's
what's gonna happen in this episode
everything that's gonna happen with this
patient is somehow gonna turn into a
poker hand what's interesting about
poker is that it's a lot like life
making a difficult decision you're not
always going to have all your
information available at your disposal
right because life is crazy and things
change all the time there's variables so
there's a lot of luck involved in life
that's the same thing that happens in
poker skill can only take you so far
there's a huge luck component if your
opponent has only one card that will
beat you despite the fact that every
other card is going to work in your
favor they may win and if they win it
doesn't mean that they outplayed you it
means that they got lucky the same thing
that can happen in life you can make a
great decision with all the information
available at your disposal and yet you
could still lose or have a bad outcome
follow my finger with your eyes
foreign
weren't you at the same party
I don't drink
I just popped pills would you reach out
to grab my cane
what's wrong abnormal control of his
muscles Dr cuty's message said it was
just dehydration from diarrhea she's
wrong I love house but the way he jumps
to knowing that there's something more
Sinister happening with this child from
hearing the basic story
it's a little extra some children when
they have diarrhea especially bloody
diarrhea with stable vital signs stable
Labs can act a little bit strange and as
time goes on they improve by him taking
a special interest in the story just
from hearing that story is a little
unrealistic two cases
same symptoms what the six-year-olds and
seven-year-olds have in common this kid
doesn't have kidney failure he will I
was treating a 73 year old woman who
went through this progression of
symptoms the last of which was
in case any of you missed that class in
med school that one's untreatable to a
colonoscopy and a six-year-old kid who
probably has nothing worse than some
food poisoning if you happen to find any
purple papules do me a favor and grab a
slice I want to check for erdheim
Chester how does he know what that is
I've never even heard of it I don't know
how you justify doing a colonoscopy on a
child with a single episode of bloody
diarrhea and a stomachache with normal
vital signs normal Labs just off of the
fear that there could be a rare
potentially life-threatening condition
that hasn't yet presented itself in any
other way outside of ataxia and bloody
diarrhea doing a colonoscopy while it's
a common procedure it's not a benign
procedure things can go wrong you can
rupture the colon you can have an
infection I mean if something negative
happens as a result of the colonoscopy
and you find nothing that's horrible you
did that to the child you know how
people see the Virgin Mary in danishes
and stuff
someone died 12 years ago and house
doesn't know why Cass sees that case now
and paint peeling and
clouds I agree with him and yes like I
said before residents don't do all the
procedures you would get a
gastroenterologist to do the colonoscopy
Internal Medicine residents don't just
do colonoscopies on their own this is
crazy why am I getting so upset about
this it's just a show chases negative
prayer and I'm Chester let me see I
still don't know what that is
[Music]
sir that's exactly what we said before
Garden variety viral gastroenteritis can
we go back to the party do a kidney
biopsy
what's up
on a whim is crazy there's no proof that
this is what's happening you have to
monitor the child watch the symptoms act
clinically
ego check it colonoscopy was clean and
the biopsy was negative for erdheim
Chester so he's gonna be all right it
was just some sort of virus
um what's that
urine but it's brown
it means kidneys are shutting down
still think it's not the same case now
you can start thinking that it's
something else doctor has had a patient
a while back who exhibits those symptoms
as your son then you know what's wrong
no so what do you know we know the
likely course the disease will take
which is she had multiple system
failures what happened to her
she died 24 hours after her admission
look telling patients information once
you know what is really important
because you want to honor uh the idea of
autonomy where a patient has the ability
to act upon their own body uh with the
best information possible in this case
it would be the patient's parents
because the child can make decisions for
himself however if you have incomplete
information and that information is very
worrisome and it's not going to bring
any value to the patients and only going
to bring anxiety maybe best leave that
information out until you have a more
concrete plan or answer otherwise we're
just creating a lot of anxiety a lot of
worry and essentially telling these
parents your child might die today
because we don't know what we're doing
brain's been infiltrated by a small Mass
we think pituitary looks that way
explains a low blood pressure
[Applause]
pretty much confirms the lymphoma
started asteroid prednisone did anyone
see the lymphoma no we saw a mess the
location was consistent we didn't see
any in the blood either
my blood's still show no spindling or
abnormal nuclei nothing on immuno
chemistries either it's not an lymphoma
sounds like he's having an anaphylactic
reaction to something and his throat's
closing up
honey just relax
and breathe
look at the right eye shrimp that's not
Kawasaki's no
it's small but it's there Esther didn't
have a mass in her heart Ian's younger
take more of a pounding Esther died
before the disease reached her heart the
disease made it mass and made it fast it
could be bacteria muscle connective
tissue the kid can't take any more
theories only thing we know is that
whatever that mess is that's what he's
got
we need a piece of it
I'm doing a biopsy you're gonna do a
biopsy on the kids hard come on house
stand out again
Cardiac Arrest
code blue come on Pebbles
chest compressions chest compressions
chest compressions before you shock
again
so when you shock you right away go back
to chest compression chest compressions
chest compression
all this time without chest compression
is the blood not circulating can someone
do some chest compressions
back he can't stand it he goes all in
he's sure he's won
I call
I flip him
pocket aces
I nailed his ass
what did he get from that story God you
gotta look we're hiding oh the aces were
High duh
testing for erdheim Chester disease
all right all right I'm pausing and I'm
looking up what erdheim Chester is
because this is ridiculous erdheim
Chester disease it's a rare type of slow
growing blood cancer in earnheim Chester
the excess production of histiocytes AKA
histiocytosis leads to inflammation that
could damage organs and tissues
throughout the body causing them to be
thick and dense scarred fibrotic and
this tissue damage may lead to organ
failure I thought they tested for this
this and if they did a kidney biopsy
they would have found this I don't know
where he's going with this this is a
disease that probably happens one in a
million kind of appropriate for a house
episode he tested negative so did Esther
he's lied yeah the tumors got it in for
you diseases don't lie fine it didn't
lie it's slow playlist We biopsy the
colon it hadn't reached the GI tract yet
it's there now
see this liver his lungs you want it to
be there
because then you didn't screw up 12
years ago you can't waste our one test
on the one disease we know it's not
run the test why didn't they do the
kidney biopsy
take your time and say it loud
they turn red
cd68 positive
[Music]
so dramatic
I feel like
start the treatment
ER this is how the genetics United this
is how the U.S national Library of
Medicine describes it it's a rare type
of slow growing blood cancer how is this
child dying in 48 hours I don't know
something about this seems shady had
they just followed regular protocol
consulted the proper Physicians instead
of instead of having house run amok with
this case this would have been solved so
much quicker so much simpler without the
child suffering these side effects so
Esther can rest peaceful now huh
yeah I've told you in the past that I
take your comments seriously well now
I'm putting my money where my mouth is
and watching an episode that you asked
me to watch here we go House MD episode
three stories
[Music]
it's three guys walk into a clinic
their legs hurt
in less than two hours one of these
three
will be tossed out of the hospital
because they were faking it to score
narcotics and one will be very close to
death where is the pain localized it
started just above my ankle and it's
radiating up
so what should we do first family
history indicative of leg pain that's a
very short list any history of bone
cancer osteogenesis imperfecta or
multiple myeloma
could be a blood issue we should run a
CBC and a D-dimer
and get an MRI Mr MRI or a pet scan
they're asking him questions really out
of order in medical school you're taught
to go with the opqrst model uh o being
on set P being provocative palliative uh
Q being the quality of the pain R
radiation of the pain S as the severity
of the pain and T timing which could
mean like time of day or if they've ever
had this issue in the past you don't
just randomly start asking family
history out of nowhere because if you
start asking that it could lead you down
a line of questioning where you're going
to spend a lot of time and not get any
valuable info you want the high yield
stuff up front sorry thanks for playing
patience dead you killed him
we had no time to run any tests there's
nothing we could do we had time to look
at the leg
puncture snake bite that would be my
guess so A lot of times when you have an
open wound like this Farmer's presenting
with you have to think obviously about
bug bites animal bites that sort of
thing because we're on the Northeast
Coast we always jump to Lyme disease
ticks
too much pain to be a slip disc could be
herniated and impinging the nerve root
or it could be referred pain from his
groin sir are you getting pain
it's curling it's not the Back Sir where
are you getting out of me it's not gonna
tell us anything if we don't get him out
of paint give him 50 milligrams of
Demerol we have no history he could be
allergic what do I do we can't diagnose
a lot of Screams better than killing him
with painkillers that
all right there's ways you can
distinguish whether someone's actually
in pain or not someone's in horrendous
pain their heart rate's going to go up
you can't fake that you can't make your
heart rate go up while you're faking
pain second of all you can when you're
doing your physical exam there's ways to
test if someone's really having pain I
do this all the time in the hospital
I'll put pressure on an area while the
patient is looking at me and I'll ask if
it hurts if they're screaming in pain uh
I'll change the subject or I'll ask him
about something else is going on but
leave my hand on the area where they're
still having pain and while I'm talking
to them I'll generally start increasing
pressure on that area they're not
jumping in pain it's either as not as
bad as they say it is or they may be
pain seeking exhibiting pain seeking
Behavior this example doesn't look like
a person's faking pain you did exactly
what his attending did and that was the
proper way to handle the case yeah the
guy used him as a dealer you're going to
see a lot of drug-seeking behavior in
your practice and there's a reason it
works
start making you feel better really fast
he's having an allergic reaction bag
paddles and happy
he's not gonna stay that way the reason
you give the Epi is not because his
heart's about to stop is because his
Airway is closing from having an
anaphylactic attack to what looks like
the snake anti-venom so you need to give
epinephrine immediately usually to the
upper thigh or some other muscular
region where it can get well absorbed
very quickly let's say we take five
get some coffee go pee it's funny like
he's fine with the medical students
going out to do that nowadays all the
medical students will be buried in their
phones trying to Google what the answer
is or Google what the possibilities are
what a good doctor means in medicine has
changed from those who know the most to
those who can get the best information
in the most efficient way possible
because there's so much information it's
being updated so quickly it's almost
impossible to be up to date on every
single study on every single subject
I've heard that there was five studies
coming out per minute in the scientific
field so it's impossible to stay up to
date with every piece of literature but
if you're very good with internet
research you're very good with verifying
sources you're very good at reading
Journal articles and understanding which
one's a quality one versus not you can
make a good decision and possibly the
best decision for your patient from
being able to research oh
the Patient responded to epinephrine and
the allergic reaction was arrested
fortunately the patient continues to
deteriorate maybe the snake wrangler was
wrong about the type we call if access
the Venom test confirmed it's a timber
rattlesnake
no it's not notice the volume I skimmed
over that and the gender and the
coloring jump right to the name of the
snake 200 milligrams
our guy got bit less than four hours ago
there's no way there's no way a snake
regenerates that much venom that quickly
we're supposed to know how fast snakes
make their venom nope
unless you got a patient bit by one okay
that was just ridiculous I mean I get I
get that house has to know a lot but he
doesn't know how fast snakes regenerate
their venom that's just insane uh I
don't know I guess now I know that too
but where does he get that snakes Venom
regeneration it hurts again
[Music]
came back
on average drug addicts are stupid
we're gonna put this hard rubber tube up
here urethra and into your bladder maybe
a little uncomfortable I'd be getting
some sort of anesthetic we're concerned
about allergic reactions today
[Music]
the guy can handle a rod in his penis
for half an hour he's really sick okay
um you don't just put a catheter in
because you want to see how serious
someone is about getting
medications there are ways to check for
people who are malingering malingering
is basically when a person is trying to
act sick in order to to get some sort of
secondary gain like drugs like a day off
work like disability these things do
happen and you need to consider them not
first and foremost in your mind but they
knew do need to be in your thought
process in your differential wrong snake
you've tried every other Andy Venom we
had we're too late
he's dying you're dying
in a few hours
there's nothing we can do except deal
with the pain
I need to go home
you're not going home
but my dog
what will happen to my dog
neighbors don't like him
so the Humane Society take advantage no
they won't
ever maybe maybe my hand it wasn't a
snake bite was it
I assume that Cujo bit one of your
neighbors a while back
you tell me that he bits you and I gotta
report it because she was gonna record
he gets the chair
I don't know if that's how it works
the good news is you might just live
the bad news is your Doc's gonna die
residents don't go to people's homes and
steal the dogs and swab the mouth this
just doesn't happen they would call the
local dog catcher I don't know someone
from the Humane Society to come and get
the dog bring it in test the mouth and
then they'll deliver them the results
residents don't do this because then
their employment insurance would be
through the roof because they're always
undergoing these crazy risks it'd be two
nuts
you call that ball of yarn what color is
your pee yellow color is your blood red
what colors did I use
red yellow and brown and brown what
causes brown waste which means the
kidneys are shutting down why
trauma and that his history would
indicate
what are you missing
muscle death
wrapped on my license
not your case
nothing wrong with the consult
dying muscle leaks myoglobin it's toxic
to the kidneys medical students were
saying that it was trauma or damage they
just weren't saying it the right way so
he's being really mean to them I don't
condone this kind of pimping dog's
mouths are pretty filthy but they have
natural antibodies to fight off most of
the stuff we don't
that's why dog bikes can be so nasty
he's right dog bites can be nasty but
actually human bites are worse if you
look at the infection rate from an
untreated human bite versus a dog bite
human bites are actually more likely to
get infected and that's because human
mouths have a much
greater range of bacteria and viruses
that live in our human mouths as
compared to dogs we may need to remove
the leg
I still don't know what this gentleman's
problem is he has muscle damage from
what I don't I'm not following and what
did the MRI show
his MRI showed that the leg pain wasn't
caused by the self-injection
caused by an infection
compartment syndrome was an aneurysm
that clotted it
leading to an infarction
house
we have to do the surgery now I get why
you guys recommended this episode I was
wondering what happened to houses like
unless this is a whole thing is a farce
it would probably take a few days to
diagnose it because it's such a unique
and rare condition that it wouldn't
appear at the top of your list if you're
thinking of aneurysm at the top of your
list you're going to be doing a lot of
unnecessary MRIs and missing a lot of
problems that are much more common so
you need to think horses not zebras but
I know since this is House MD zebras are
usually the first thing they talk about
do a bypass restore the circulation the
amputation is safer for you or me the
blockage of blood flow for day blockage
yes
cause muscle cell death when those cells
die they release cytokines and potassium
you restore the blood flow instead of
just lopping it all off then all that
crap gets washed back into my system as
cytokines could cause organ failure and
the potassium could cause cardiac arrest
on the other hand and just get the use
of my leg back this is really
interesting so whenever you have a part
of the body that doesn't have blood
going through it for a very long period
of time that body the part of the body
dies it becomes necrotic that's the
medical term for it because of ischemia
lack of oxygen it dies because blood is
bringing oxygen to those areas when a
muscle dies for example it releases
these inflammatory cells called
cytokines it also releases potassium
because when a cell ruptures the first
thing that it releases or the most
important thing that it releases is
potassium and having too high of a
potassium in your bloodstream is very
dangerous it can be lethal and having
too much inflammatory cells can also be
lethal and cause organ damage so you
have that problem going on because his
muscles have been without blood for a
long period of time in his leg but then
as you restore blood flow you have
reperfusion of that area you can also
get even more inflam inflammation going
and inflammatory markers going because
he's bringing healthy blood into damaged
blood and that Sparks even more
inflammation and that's why Dr Cuddy's
actually encouraging him to go for the
amputation to leave all those cytokines
and inflammatory cells and potassium in
the leg and not cause even more
inflammation and pain but I also
understand where he's coming from where
he doesn't want to lose his leg it's
risky what he's saying uh it's not
advisable what he's saying and I could
see a lot of Surgeons turning down this
procedure because they don't see that
this is ideal for him as a doctor you
always want to do what's best for the
patient and let the patient decide
what's best for their bodies but if
they're telling you to do a procedure
that you think is very risky and
unnecessary you're well within your
means to try and convince them otherwise
if you were right the pain would be
subsiding you'd be getting better
no it's not
the leg off
leg
It's My Life
the middle ground you were talking about
we go in to have the dead muscle
still some risk of reperfusion injury
but give me the forms you need signed
[Music]
if our house I'd be pretty mad about
that but then again uh this is why the
bioethics committee comes into play
because you're technically doing
something the patient doesn't want and
has explicitly said he doesn't want but
you know it's better for them it's such
a thin line I'm not sure what the right
call here is but as medical proxy she
does have say over what happens to his
body right now
because of the extent of the muscle
removed
the utility of the patient's leg was
severely compromised
because of the time delay in making the
diagnosis
continues to experience chronic pain a
lot of people don't realize this but
when you're on chronic opioid
medications which is just essentially
it's a masking agent for the pain it's
not treating your pain just hiding the
pain when you're on that for a long
period of time it changes the chemistry
of your brain and actually makes you
feel something known as hyperalgesia
where you feel more pain and are more
sensitive to pain so that sometimes in a
patient who has chronic pain you have to
reduce the amount of pain medications
they take for them over time to feel
less pain it's a paradoxical complicated
concept but I've actually had a patient
that is 81 years old 30 years of back
pain he's been on opiate medications for
two years he's taken morphine and when
he came to me said Dr barshowsky You're
My Last Hope and when I talk to him
about it I said that I know this is
going to sound crazy but I have to lower
your dose and eventually get you off of
your narcotic medications if you want to
improve this pain and actually right now
we're at a point where he's not taking
any narcotic medications for his pain
he's going to the gym he's golfing he's
felt better than ever narcotics aren't
always the right answer they have a
place there's definitely a role for them
but they're not always the right answer
they definitely have harms and sometimes
those harms outweigh the benefits that
we need not lie about that she had no
right to do that she had the proxy she
knew he didn't want the surgery she
saved his life oh we don't know that
maybe it would have been fine it doesn't
matter it's the patient's call the
patient's an idiot
little do they know they usually are
[Music]
it wasn't clear to me in the episode if
they understand that it's him because
they were still talking smack at the end
of that uh at the end of that episode I
do think that sometimes he crosses the
line is a little rude but that's Dr
house he's just got this personality
that's like angry and wants everyone to
see him as the bad guy when in reality
he wants to do the right thing and he
wants to help people but he comes all
harsh at times I feel like whenever he
says a patient is dumb or doesn't do the
right thing he's essentially thinking
that because he's thinking about the
mistake he made of not amputating his
legs and going through all those
surgeries and procedures and having this
chronic pain issue when if he just would
have gotten an amputation got a
replacement you know there's so many
ways to get a prosthetic nowadays Dr
house has clinic hours just like I do so
today I'm going to react to some of his
funniest and most unusual patient
encounters where do you feel the pain
in the back of my head here uh-huh it's
picarious sign I'll leave down by your
third trimester I'm not in school
neither is your fetus
oh God you didn't know you were pregnant
how do you you know that just from my
headache I know because of the tight
shirts stretched over the swollen boobs
the salt craving imported into the
clinic the motion sickness patch he's
like an Amazon algorithm that knows what
you purchased so he thinks he knows you
it's like how Tick Tock has been
pointing out things about us because it
knows us so well because of what we
watch and what we search and what we
click Dr house was the original
algorithm I'm a virgin
so is my fiance
I believe him aren't there other ways I
could get pregnant like
sitting on a toilet seat absolutely
there would need to be a guy sitting
between you and the toilet seat but yes
absolutely
oh that was a good line I'm waiting here
for six hours
am I a father or not
but
she also didn't cheat on you normally
sperm eats egg DNA meets DNA goes back
to her place sells divide nine months
later Joy is bundled abnormally an egg
could have two naturally occurring gene
mutations that don't naturally occur
together spontaneous calcium Spike could
prep the egg for fertilization without
sperm in a division mistake to let the
eggs split up without ever needing male
DNA at all Jesus I've never heard of
this the humans it's only ever been
theorized but it's never proved
well obviously on house it's going to
happen your daughter has only maternal
DNA I'd personally check this five times
in seven months you will have
a virgin birth
Merry Christmas
[Music]
there's no way this has ever been
reported let's try
who cares it's beautiful what was he
looking onward half as well maintained
as that pigeons wouldn't have the nerve
to poop on it looking into the nose with
an autoscope you're not going to get a
lot of information usually you have to
go deeper with a fiber optic camera
which is like one of those cameras that
you go in with a remote and you could
see it on a video screen that's where
you're gonna get good info you can
really visualize the turbulence the
posterior nasal passageways you can even
see the vocal cords once you go a little
further down good grooming is important
is that a shot
people who judge you on your appearance
When you entered I noted your shirt
hadn't been pressed you hadn't shaved in
quite some time I extrapolated you are a
person for whom detail was not a major
concern I like that he's pointing it
correctly most people point it up but if
you're pointing it up you're just
looking at the front of the nose so he
is pointing in the correct direction at
least I was worried you might apply that
same standard in you can use toenail
clippers up there whoa don't use toenail
covers in your nose folks they're longer
so they allow me to better reach the
other hairs bro get one of those tools
that you go in you press the button and
it just has like a protected little
shaver in there you've got athlete's
foot in your nose oh so he basically has
a tinia a fungal infection in his nose
probably because his nail clipper had
toenail fungus but house would not have
been able to know that without a looking
at his toe and confirming that he has an
onico mycosis which is a toenail fungus
and B that this is in fact fungal spores
a fungal rash especially in an enclosed
environment like this it's just going to
look like irritating on a mucous
membrane you're not going to know
exactly what's the cause sore throat
oh that's a lot of blood maybe close the
curtains there champ but give the
patient some privacy
stop lupus well not everyone can operate
a zipper of the up down he's sweating a
lot so he's either going into shock he
has an infection a fever something's
going on my new girlfriend
never been with a guy who wasn't
circumcised
so she freak he tried to circumcise
himself
huh
I got some box cutters and uh box cutter
Abraham did it I sterilized them
I've got to get a plastic surgeon get
the Tweaky back in the rubber that's
probably the most real part of house
that you get a plastic surgeon or you
get a specialist involved because Dr
House can't be a specialist for
everything top of my head's killing me
you spent a week doing top of head in
anatomy I know just where it is
ow oh my God how did he know those okay
if someone says the top of their head is
hurting them and then you push on the
sinuses and the sinuses are tender
that's interesting your sinuses are
clogged jetting by the scratches on your
hands I'm guessing a new cat
yeah it was my mother's she's dead you
keep a dead cat
no yeah so if you have an allergic
reaction to a cat that can cause
obviously congestion in your nasal
passageways it can cause your eustachian
tube which is the pressure relieving
tube inside the the sinuses and ear
canal to get inflamed close up because
it's a very short not short very narrow
tube and when it gets inflamed it closes
off and it feels like there's a lot of
pressure in here and a lot of people
want antibiotics for their sinus
infections whereas most sinus infections
are caused by a viral cause not
bacterial therefore you don't need
antibiotics you have to knock off an
hour early today you know why
because I kiss my boss's ass you ever do
that
I think she just said yes because she
wants to reinforce that behavior wants
me to kiss a lot of other people's ass
like she wants me to kiss yours what
would you want a Doctor Who holds your
hand while you die or a doctor who
ignores you while you get better I guess
it would particularly suck to have a
doctor who ignores you while you die
I should go you think it's gonna come
out on its own I just do not understand
his diagnosing ability he
he's like a dolphin but a doctor dolphin
you can make the echo of the sound
bounce off his intestinal walls and tell
him that there's something in his butt
how did you you've been here half an
hour you haven't sat down that tells me
it's location or he's nervous you
haven't told me what it is that tells me
it's humiliating I have a little birdie
carved under your arm and tells me you
have a high tolerance for humiliation so
I figured it's not Emerald I've been a
doctor 20 years you're not going to
surprise me
it's an MP3 player an iPod what are we
gonna do
I'm gonna wait
maybe ask maybe do some Imaging maybe
see if there's an obstruction my guy
small bowel obstructions happen usually
because of a post-surgical adhesion but
here too he's been using his inhaler not
in the past few days he's um only 10 I
worry about children taking such strong
medicine so frequently
what happened to your life the doctor
probably was concerned about the
strength of the medicine too she
probably weighed that danger against the
danger of not breathing yeah so for a
child with asthma I see parents run into
this issue quite often a lot of times
have concerns about using a preventive
inhale of which you're supposed to use
every single day and you're not supposed
to use these willy-nilly the way that we
treat asthma is a step up plan so we
start with the lowest amount of
intervention and then we work our way up
depending on the symptoms depending on
the severity of the illness and
sometimes you need to take a preventive
in order to decrease the amount of times
you need to use your emergency inhaler
to decrease the amount of times you have
nighttime attacks and most importantly
to decrease the amount of times you end
up in a hospital intubated that's why we
do it and something interesting about
asthma is if you're having an acute
asthma attack and you're in a hospital
you're breathing really fast and you're
trying to breathe out it's really
important to know that if you just start
fatiguing and breathing slower even
though you haven't improved your
wheezing that could be a sign that
you're fatiguing and that's a reason you
need to get into beta to actually buy
you time in order for the asthma attack
to pass House MD actually does clinic
hours which is basically general
medicine Family Medicine exactly the
type of doctor that I am let's see some
of his wildest encounters asthma they
said they'd fix it but it didn't make
any difference at all asthma step-up
plan if you're using a rescue inhaler
too often AKA you're albuterol you might
need a controller medication to prevent
the asthma attacks from happening some
people have specific triggers that they
can avoid or they can take medicines
targeting those triggers you like to
think about allergy medicines for that
you could take your traditional
antihistamines or maybe even a
medication like singular you got to
think outside the box with asthma are
you using your inhaler all the time go
through one a week
sure you're using it right a lot of
patients especially children tend to not
use it correctly because they weren't
properly educated they would benefit
from a spacer this is what a spacer
looks like
come on there's images on the bottle of
what you're supposed to do that's never
gonna happen experiencing fatigue and
weakness usually he's stronger than ox
102 year old Ox
102 year old ox and elderly Ox just
tingling and his feet in his legs I want
a full battery of tests well maybe we
want to check if he's diabetic because
in that case you could treat that and
you could change quality of life
tremendously it's nice of you to float
your friend he's not my friend he's my
father he's 22 years older than me well
that's truce if we had his jowls done
statistically if he didn't have these
symptoms he'd be like most people of his
age dead for the past several decades go
to tests I'm sick you have a bad case of
natural causes first of all he should do
some tests but I wonder what they think
it is that's like one of the first
questions I ask as a doctor he's 102.
his next test is an autopsy look I I
love the old man but I gotta get him out
of the damn house he needs to be in a
care facility so tell him he's a big
boy that's very generous when you were
30.
pretend to run the tests we don't do
that you can't bribe doctors to give you
the results that you want doctors really
shouldn't be accepting gifts I think
it's over 30 I think that's what our
tests say when a patient bakes you a
cake it's fine but if a patient bakes
you a cake with gold flakes on it you
have to say no I love him but he can't
let go
40 bucks [__] can I can't do anything
without him helping me like I'm senile
you could give him five bucks
skip the blood work tell my son it's
Grim news I need to be in a nursing home
I think that's actually a dis if a
patient thinks they can buy you that
means you're sending off the wrong
signals and if two patients think they
can buy you that means you probably
should be retiring test results
it's my recommendation that you move
into a home with round-the-clock care I
can't believe it
can't my son give me round-the-clock
here not unless you've done your
two-year certification in Tiburon swab
technology tip you're on what technology
it's made up just because he has a
little tingling and some trouble feeling
hot and cold that's the spinal oh my God
the thalmic pathway that's fine God I
don't remember the pathways anymore show
me your denture cream he has zinc
poisoning
from denture cream you have to take so
much of it trust me he never leaves home
without it obviously you use pop about a
tube a day she explains all your
symptoms medically there's no reason to
go anywhere he solved the case that the
patients didn't want himself you're not
pregnant
well I told you that you were pregnant
based on your hormone levels you've had
a miscarriage well that could happen we
can see that yeah I haven't even been on
a date right
since it's physically impossible to have
sex without someone buying you dinner I
haven't had sex fine
have it your way Immaculate Conception
or how about this Dr House the patient
has a tumor that's secreting the hormone
that you think is responsible for her
lost pregnancy and you think about her
cancer potential diagnosis instead of
assuming she's a liar what do I do
well it's obvious
to start a religion take birth control
if you truly believe that she was
pregnant as a result of sexual activity
scratch your results back no GHB no
nothing means you're having sex and
you're lying about it no I haven't had
any in over a year I just wake up really
exhausted oh my God is she sleepwalking
my ex was in the apartment downstairs
he's always calling me always wanting to
get back together complaining about
mixed signals we had a sleep lab in the
basement
something else will get you away from
your ex for a night see when I send
patients to a sleep lab it's usually is
a diagnosed sleep apnea which is
basically where you stop breathing for a
period of time and as a result you wake
up and you're not really able to get
good quality sleep but as a result you
get increased risk of all these other
conditions like hypertension cardiac
disease even diabetes in some cases
these were your brain waves at 2 45 a.m
and here it comes there's an Abrupt jump
from slow weight sleep this indicates
partial sleep arousal most common type
is subnambulism sleepwalking that would
explain why I'm so tired when I wake up
yes
yes also while you were pregnant
I had sex in my sleep only in a medical
drama no formula just mommy healthy
natural breast milk I hope you also
supplement with vitamin D 400 IU or 10
micrograms her whole face just got
swollen like this overnight
maybe a little slap cheek a little
parvovirus b19 no fever
Blends normal do you go
glance normal my guy feel the glass
vaccination dates we're not vaccinating
house please handle this with some
empathy please empathetic approach think
they don't work I think some
multinational pharmaceutical company
wants me to think they work pad their
bottom line you know another really good
business
teeny tiny baby colleagues
she has a
menstruals are in bed all day plus she's
super depressed a red nose could be a
sign of a viral illness perhaps
allergies frequent rubbing also patient
looks a little bit pale heavy Menses
with menstrual pain could be related to
fibroids she wants birth control pills
for her PMS I guess or is she pregnant
judging by the redness Rancher mom's
nostrils and the tissue she's got
conveniently stashed in her wristband
I'd say her problem is more likely a URI
URI upper respiratory infection upper
respiratory infection I also think she's
got a problem with the sac Sac stupid
American child if you want the pill all
you have to do is to walk into any
health clinic in Jersey alone and ask
for it how in the world did he know this
I would rack my brain for days trying to
help the patient he just assumes the
worst how do you even function this way
pepper cold no that's been your ovaries
assuming you haven't had a stroke if you
ever had a blood clot no super also ask
if she smokes Dr house that's important
I'm taking the decongestants but she's
not getting better
what
her boobs are bigger is she taking the
birth control how could you get the
mixed up they come in a little wheel
they don't look anything like
decongestants
Guinea
no you gave her the wrong pills
you speak Mandarin what is happening in
this episode he speaks every language he
knows every body part he knows every
snake poison and rat toe so when did
this start a couple weeks ago
I didn't want to get pregnant Jake's not
into rubbers so I got on the jelly
you have an infection you need a sample
I brought the jar wait she literally is
putting jelly okay we have a
neurological problem here there's
something wrong with my brain
oh yeah okay I'm gonna give you some
antibiotics and you probably shouldn't
have sex for a while how long on an
evolutionary basis I'd recommend forever
so mean I think it goes without saying
but strawberry jelly is not a birth
control option never thought I'd say
that on this channel but it's not